"Félicie aussi"
C'est dans un coin du bois d'Boulogne
Que j'ai rencontré Félicie
Elle arrivait de la Bourgogne
Et moi j'arrivais
en taxi
Je trouvais vite une occasion
D'engager la conversation
Il faisait un temps superbe
Je me suis assis sur l'herbe
Félicie
aussi
Je pensais les arbres bourgeonnent
Et les gueules–de–loups boutonnent
Félicie
aussi
Près de nous sifflait un merle
La rosée faisait des perles
Félicie
aussi
Un clocher sonnait tout proche
Il avait une drôle de cloche
Félicie
aussi
Afin de séduire la petite chatte
Je l'emmenais dîner chez Chartier
Comme elle est fine et délicate
Elle prit un pied de cochon grillé
Et pendant qu'elle mangeait le sien
J'lui fis du pied avec le mien
Je pris un homard sauce tomate
Il avait du poil aux pattes
Félicie
aussi
Puis une sorte de plat aux nouilles
On aurait dit une andouille
Félicie
aussi
Je m'offris une gibelotte
Elle embaumait l'échalote
Félicie
aussi
Puis une poire et des gaufrettes
Seulement la poire était blette
Félicie
aussi
La ramant tournant la tête
Elle murmura : "quand tu voudras"
Alors j'emmenai ma conquête
Dans un hôtel tout près de là
C'était l'hôtel d'Abyssinie
Et du Calvados réuni
J'trouvais la chambre ordinaire
Elle était pleine de poussière
Félicie
aussi
Je m'lavais les mains bien vite
Le lavabo avait une fuite
"rires" - "Félicie" (public)
"aussi" (public)
"rires"
Sous l'armoire y avait une cale
Car elle était toute bancale
Félicie
aussi
Et des draps de toile molle
Me chatouillaient les guibolles
Félicie
aussi
"applaudissements"